hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to red it's 5050
challenge now I'm only gonna warn you
one gird your loins gird your lungs gird
whatever you can because I'm about to
subject myself to unending horrifying
brutal bloody madness and maybe a few
boobs along the way don't worry I'll
censor what I can for you guys but just
be warned they're not warning for you
guys I'm just going to go for this cat
versus balloons compilation that sounds
amazing
or aftermath of a girl who fell into a
lake full of piranhas not safe for life
seriously blue look at you go get the
balloon oh so happy I'm so happy alright
okay that's good good we did that we
survived it surprisingly man murdered in
basketball court or baboon eating baby
gazelle alive oh no the following events
shocked our cameraman oh no oh no wow Oh
nature is horrifying oh okay I'm out I'm
out I'm out
I'm out I'm out I'm out on that one I'm
out I call quitsies I call quit these
I'm allowed to do that another in the
loss column boy
alternative rock song from the 90s or
guide chops out a dead Bisons liver and
another dude eats it raw
oh god it's the Bison liver ha ha ha oh
you don't have to do this I don't know
why you always I mean livers fine I
guess it's a perfectly edible part but
you don't have to do it right here in
the middle of the wherever the hell you
are all right I'm okay I'm all right I'm
all right about that a man who had his
leg torn off after a bike accident or a
dog skateboarding at a skate park
now that sounds Pleasant that sounds
cool even Oh No Oh the leg Oh where's
his look Oh where's somebody help him
we're not helping him
oh don't show there's the leg well ok
[ __ ] we found the [ __ ] leg well we're
off to a wondrous start I seem to be
losing a lot more than I did in the last
bench Erica alright ok uh puppy tries to
eat a lemon freaks out adorable
idiot eats a dead wolf spider and freaks
out why is he eating a dead wolf spider
number 1 and why does he freak out just
because he's like not okay with eating
the dead wolves later I mean I can sum
oh it's 11 oh it's a dog lemon yes
it's a Bernese Mountain Dog oh so cute
it sister puppy
hahaha what is it I don't know it's a
mystery it's a little bit stirring all
of them happy that's a good one that's
it okay whoo-whoo-whoo-whoo cue peacock
spider playing bongos or spider crawling
out of ear canal I was the bongos I'm
seeing that gift before
Cassidy cook qualifying for the Olympics
or bold in infected testicles being
removed Oh
limping real for the opening sir
come on Cassidy Oh beautiful okay but
the [ __ ] is this 1960s ad executives
salute Christina Hendricks is asked
slightly not safe for work our dentist
works on person suffering from dental
implant infection that's the deckle ah
[ __ ] Oh
ah that so much wood why is this so much
blood Oh comic skin yeah oh my god yeah
bite me shouting about my skin I'm
talking about my skin crawling ah okay
I'm fine I'm brief so ha ha ha ha ha ha
do that I'm gonna do that not gonna do
that not in it all right
cat falls asleep while biting toe or
butt augmentation surgery and I want to
mention that's probably not good but I'm
actually skipping over some of the worst
ones which usually end up with either
decapitation or dismemberment of some
sort or Oh
Oh Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
hi Madge America was fiercely attacking
that go with all its might and those old
suckered oh oh oh no hey how's it going
all all right ha ha ha Hugh Jackman
singing on stage or kid breaks arm tries
to reset it but only makes it worse
and the reason I'm picking this one is
because when I broke my arm when I was
like in the sixth or seventh grade I
reset it myself so I can relate if this
is the kid it breaks his arm and resets
it only to make it worse it's the case
oh that is [ __ ]
Oh blow me [ __ ] oh [ __ ] push it back
[Applause]
grab the boy get my board get my board
oh gotta get bad yeah that's important
yeah way to go oh yeah it's weird
it's weird it's weird when you break
your arm like cuz at first when I broke
my arm it didn't hurt at all it didn't
hurt it was like a staircase not quite
like that but more of a like extreme
staircase and then it didn't hurt until
I tried to reset it and I reset it
pretty good back bed but what's he doing
leveraging it against the ground like
that I just grabbed it and and put it
back into place and even the doctor said
that it was almost perfect until he had
to really break it to reset it better so
don't do that don't do what I did leave
it to professionals so anyway that is
all for 50/50 that I'm gonna do for
today I think I'm scarred enough for
life and I think I've scarred you guys
enough as it is if you want to go see
this please don't I'm not even going to
come close to keeping you recommend
to go doing this let me be the filter
for the horror that is here because
there is much worse on here than this
also before you guys go I just wanted to
mention I've been trying out this new
release catch I'm releasing videos at 1
& 4 for the most reason that it makes my
life a lot easier it makes it so that
I'm available when the videos get
released and that way I can actually
look at comments and I can respond to
people and I can actually not stress
about waking up before 8:00 a.m. to make
sure that the video release is OK I
actually have time in the morning to
exercise and do language and practice
all this stuff but in other news it's
also because it was weird to me that I
was releasing videos when most people
were in school so I'm going to try it
out that's one in four Pacific Standard
Time which is like 4:00 and 7:00 Eastern
Time so I'm going to give it a go and
see how it works let me know what you
think and thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you for watching me
subject myself to Horrors unknown if you
want to see the previous version of this
as I did check the link of the
description below so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye